we were at the Honda studios in Miami
Florida and we figured with us coming
here for the big week and I'm gonna
finish up the entire week with this guy
and Kurt and mooch and the rest of the
NFL gameday morning gang for an eight
and a half hour long pregame show that
starts at 9:00 a.m. Eastern on Saturday
and a half hours folks that's just in
case anybody's scoring it good to see
you Michael earth and how are you sir
I'm doing well rich I'm looking forward
to the eight and a half our pregame show
that word now are you doing all eight
and a half hours I do all eight and a
half hours yeah you know some tap out
you know Kurt's got to tap out cuz he's
got to do radio see I do my radio all
week and then get it out of the way for
Super Sunday Kurt's got radio today Wow
so he's got to prepare to walk upstairs
and sit in front of a microphone to call
a game he could do in his sleep I get it
and by the way I get it is the phrase of
me saying I don't but I'm just covering
this and I get it
he leaves mooch usually taps out too but
you're there with me are you there with
me the very end I'll fight to the end
right out here now listen we usually
have to do eight and a half hours
pregame and wait watch the game and then
what do we do oh yeah we were oh man
last time I did that was they was the
New York Super Bowl the New York Super
Bowl where I believe I go down in the
third quarter and because the game was a
blowout
I think half of my analyst for the
postgame show were taking a nap yes yeah
I was very balanced there was also a
Florida State guy that was also our
guest and Deion Sanders in a half-hour a
pregame all right and then in you know
you and then really an hour before the
game starts because you guys we have to
be off an hour before so it's really you
got nine and a half hours before the
game well I'm telling you man
it was something but it's fun to do and
we will be there before the Chiefs in
the and the 49ers and I know you spoke
to kettle this week right you go yeah I
did a great interview work you I love
that guy
I mean oh my god me too me did and gave
us some great stuff too cuz you know he
it was some surprise stuff that'll be on
the show okay there we'll have fun with
but what an incredible dude he is but
really incredible do love loves to play
the game has a big big personality loves
this WWE you know I told him I used to
love W to be they should bring it when I
was growing up in Florida brain but to
the gymnasium yeah you know told Dusty
Rhodes with the elbow and Pat song and
they used to fight each other and I was
so into it
as a kid I love this stuff and then one
time I was leaving and I saw Dustin
Rhodes and pass on smoking a cigarette
together
I was I was hurt that's what I free I
finally really okay maybe this is not
real it's not real killer goes on like
like Benja thongs where he watches WWE
for like seven eight hours straight
I'm like you know I wanted to ask me you
do know that that ain't real
he said yeah is real he said when you
come off the top rope gravity don't
gravity won't cooperate with you that's
real all right I'm gonna talk route
landing on a mattress I got you wow
these guys actually just to bring it all
full circle these guys have been kicked
in the nuts by superstar page it looks
real but you know she knows exactly
where that you did not actually yeah
right on the side yeah I watch it now
watch this also watch it I gotta tell
you Oh God
you stood in there okay what kind of
profession are you are you can practice
on somebody
crash test you mess around and miss all
you said oh I'm sorry it's gonna be too
late for that
Michael urban here on the Rich Eisen
show and the few minutes I have with you
left here the crazy thing is Kittel is
hardly even used to get to Miami they
barely thief they threw to him once in
the NFC champion game Jimmy G only threw
it eight times in that game how do you
see Super Bowl 50 for plain outer yeah
that's so crazy people have always said
you know people ask always maybe you
think you can play on a team that only
throws the ball a time I'm like of
course I can as long as they threw all
eight passes to men of course right but
but it is incredible man I think it's
gonna be a great game a fascinating game
I'm so I'm so excited about it you know
whatever happens we're going to get some
first and you get to experience some
first right you know whatever coach wins
it's his first as a head coach would
have a quarterback wins it's his first
as a quarterback you know and with all
due respect to Tom who's won a hundred
of them you know and it's great watching
that kind of greatness we want to see
that first man so I think this is going
to be an exciting exciting super I still
think that I got because I stuck with
San Francisco and I've been growing with
them for a while
I'll stick with them but I think this is
going to be one of those last guy have
the ball will win the game and it's not
worry if it's my home's now if it's
dropped below then he'll have something
to prove why and I say that asking you
this question out of respect to you even
though I won the NFL gameday morning
picks contest this year wants the most
expert accurate opinion as to what's
gonna happen at Super Bowl 54 all they
have to do is wait to hear what comes
out of my mouth you got a deal with this
guy
all the time
oh by the way that's just a little takes
a little morsel little nugget about
what's coming all 2020 what's coming for
all 17 regular-season weeks with me
having that trophy I don't know next
year we'll just see what happens we
collected burning no 17 regular-season
weeks of NFL gameday morning yeah that
trophy will be in front of me huh and
part of me thinks that this is in the
two minutes I have left
possibly mahomes is time this is his
stage his moment with all due respect to
use the phrase to that 49ers conference
for him to have his moment against that
defense in this game at this time for
this team this is San Francisco doesn't
get one more than Dallas I mean I'm
gonna bring this thing back home
sometimes we got fire being a father
they want another one in eight years
six-wheel and five try even though I'm
picking San Francisco I wouldn't like to
I love and even another man and he needs
a Super Bowl ring to submit his legacy
and I think he gets one then we start
talking about him as one of the greatest
coaches devil coaching his game he is of
one of the greatest coaches
he just needs that ring to solidify okay
I've got Witten coming on Thursdays show
that's great yeah do you think you think
he plays next year is he gonna join the
coaching staff what do you think well
IIIi think win probably oh hopefully
joins the coaching staff
you know because his comfort which was
coach Garrett and all of those guys are
no longer there yeah and I don't know if
he wants to subject himself coming back
to trying to prove something to coach
Mike McCarthy and that whole group again
you know so so III hopefully he gets
into something that he loves doing as
much as he loves playing the game
because it's probably time and they're
probably moving that's a good answer
I'm coming on to doc he'll be here too
this fall this fall real quick is he
franchise tantras you get a full PI
contract I hope he gets a full party
well III we does I hope that stick makes
a statement cuz you know dad that has
daksa forked around like if I'm got you
know those agents they want to be able
to say they got the biggest contract I'm
gonna have to go to their agents and
listen to I'm gonna let you do that the
next time go and get me this hit right
let me put this one at meal Milly Milly
in the bank and then we'll play this
game with you next time but right now I
don't have 100 million million debate
once I get that here on the second honey
milli milli you go for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app